[Music]
[Applause]
mike mayok joining us on the program
i thought about you with these pro days
and we've talked before about a pro day
but i i'm just curious as a gm or former
gm and draft analyst what should we be
looking for with these pro days
especially with these quarterbacks
i think
my whole life of pro days and that goes
back almost 20 years now
um when you mention quarterback stan
i i really
it's less about
uh the accuracy it's less about
all the things you think it would be
about and for more it's about just
personally seeing the ball pop out of a
quarterback's hands when you watch tape
it's hard sometimes to to look at
two or three quarterbacks together and
say who's got more pop more form power
more strength
unless it's a josh allen which just
jumps off the screen
okay
so when you go to a pro day
i'm looking at
feet up i want to see their footwork a
lot of these guys have never been under
center and being under center doesn't
matter as much anymore because the nfl's
in in gun most of the time now anyway
but still
you know you go back to bill walsh it's
all about footwork with quarterbacks so
do they have natural feet how quick are
their feet how quick is the released um
you know there's a the quarterback uh
matt corral from ole miss when you watch
his tape it screams quickness from the
bot from the feet up he's got arm
quickness he's got foot quickness he's
got twitch he's got accuracy i want to
see that in person
malik willis i watched that pro day on
television the other day and i agree
with daniel jeremiah the first thing
that caught me and i saw it on tape but
i wanted to see more of it he wore
shorts
right and you could see how powerful his
lower body was like you think you see
that on tape but his lower body and to
me i don't know if you how much of a
baseball guy you are but i used to love
nolan ryan
right when i was a kid i used to love
what and and i did some pitching and i
played a lot i played college baseball
and it was always about the ground up
and with the quarterback it's all a lot
it's about the ground up malik willis is
lower body i mean you just sit there go
wow that reinforces everything i saw on
tape it confirms it so you look for i
really went from a quarterback i want to
see the pop from a defensive end or a
corner
i want to see him come out defensive end
i want to see his explosion coming out
of his stance from a corner change your
direction you can see things live when
you're five yards away from the kid that
you can't really see on tape you know
what stood out for me watching willis
was his personality yeah and i don't
know how important that is looking at it
as a scout an analyst or gm
but man that stuff is contagious and it
looked like he loved playing football
and maybe i'm reading too much into it
mike
i don't think you are dan and i think
at that position
and i think that's the hardest position
in all of sports but i think one of
things you have to have is leadership
okay and natural leadership
stuff that you're not faking like i'll
give you an example uh marcus mariota
got to know him the last couple years
really cool because marcus is not that
outgoing screaming yell he's a quiet
individual but he's got confidence he's
got quiet swag
and when you get in the game you see
some of that fire come out there's
different kinds of leadership
i think what you saw with malik willis
was just a natural extrovert
and that's really cool what i'd want to
know again i wasn't there i was watching
it on tv with you and i've never met him
what i'd want to do is get in the room
with them and spend some time with them
and see how that translates 101 talk to
the people that know him
best it certainly looks like he's a
leader i love the fact did you see the
tape or the video from the senior bowl
when he was handing out clothes
to a homeless guy right so
all the stuff all the intangibles that
are so important in that position i'd
want to know more about and confirm
because it certainly looks like he
checks all those boxes and to me that
elevates him a little bit but i wonder
and you know it's the eye of the
beholder that somebody loves something
that somebody else is going to say i'm
not going to take him that high it feels
like detroit
could go in at number two at malik
willis
should they
yeah i think the old school argument
there and
and it's intriguing
is
look at it this way how many franchise
quarterbacks from the nfl today seven or
eight maybe okay they can put put a team
on their back
and go in a super bowl yeah and maybe
there's another five six seven
that you can win a super bowl with
okay that's not even half the league
when you add it up
so if
you don't have one of those guys
you don't have a chance right that's the
preface i used to have conversations
with coaches all the time and scouts
about look if if you value malik willis
on your board
if he's the 14th best player on the
board you technically should have no
business taking him at two
however
if you really believe he's the guy yeah
what does it matter where you took them
yeah
well i wonder about this that
when does that quarterback get to the
point where you go this is who he's
going to be
is it second third year fourth year
fifth year because i'm trying to figure
out tua trying to figure out baker
mayfield that like what happens next
with those two guys how would you assess
that of
you know baker doesn't have a job and
tua you know just got tyreek so
uh he better be great this year but is
this the year for uh pertua
it's a great question um
what i learned over the last few years
is that um fit really matters
okay
uh and by definition if you're a top
five draft pick you're typically going
to a poor football team
you know so
fit matters who's your offense
coordinator who's your quarterback coach
do you fit with what they're doing what
are they complimenting you with what are
they putting around you can you run the
football what's your offensive line look
like there's so many different things
that go into that and that's why with
young quarterbacks i l i like to look at
it like okay
when they're ready to play
and they're all different like i
remember uh carson wentz
when he came out north dakota state all
that kind of stuff
people were saying to me when i was the
nfl network's draft guy you know well
can he start week one and i said that
doesn't matter
doesn't matter when he's ready to start
he will whether it's week one week eight
or year two
okay but you can't do to
carson wentz or any talented young
quarterback what happened to joey
harrington or derek carr's brother
you can't just throw him in there and
let him get the crap beat out of them
for two or three years that does that's
counter-intuitive so that's a long way
of saying that i think every
quarterback's a little bit differently
different they're ready at different
levels both physically emotionally and
mentally um tua i think at this point
now you're gonna know
you know what is it year three for tua
you're gonna know
this year whether or not he can be in
that first or second group of
quarterbacks and baker mayfield
you know two years ago they were playoff
team you know he played pretty well i
think there was a lot of stuff going on
in that building this year um and
obviously they want him out of the
building and he feels the same way so my
mind on baker is kind of open
it's a different kind of fit if he gets
in the right building i think he can
play
talking to mike mayonk the former raider
gm former nfl network draft analyst
which side of the tyreek hill trade do
you like kansas city or miami
i find it so intriguing on so many
different levels dan and um
you know as a former afc west general
manager who's tried to chase
tyreke and kansas city for the last
three years i mean these sons of guns
have won six consecutive divisions and
they've been in the afc championship
game four years in a row
and so the question you ask yourself or
at least i do when i solve a trade is
right away i was like does that make
them less dynamic on offense and it
probably does now nicole hardman is
within a whisper of being just as
explosive as tyrique they signed juju
they signed valdez scantling
i trust andy reid i trust patrick
mahomes so will they be a little less
explosive probably
but the rest of the afc west which is
fascinating with that arms race they're
they're all going hey there's an opening
here
there's a little bit of an opening here
and and they've all geared up now the
miami side of it is you know they
drafted that kid last year waddle and
you want to talk about explosive yeah
that son of a gun is explosive
so that goes back to what i said a
minute ago about tua is that you know
he's got explosive weapons um if their
offensive line can play at a level they
need them to i think
i mean that they they can be a really
good footballer so i'm not i i think
both sides of this thing is intriguing
when people come up and ask why are you
not the raider gm any longer how do you
answer that
i liked how you warmed up before you
warmed me up yes i got into that one yes
i did yes that was good that was a
veteran move yes um
how do i resp say that again
how do i respond why are you no longer
the raiders gm
i i think um
when i got there there were four and
twelve team
and then we went seven and nine eight
and eight and ten and seven and
we were on the nine yard line in the
playoffs
with 35 seconds left with four shots to
tie cincinnati
who went to the super bowl which kind of
shows you how close the nfl is right
um
why am i not i think at the end of the
day dan it's it's all about the owner
has final say
and i think uh mark davis has the good
heart
uh i like mark davis personally and at
the end of the day he decided that me
and rich versace didn't get it done at
the level he wanted or that he felt like
a couple other guys could get it done at
a higher level going forward
and i have to respect that because he's
the boss
but if you beat cincinnati
are you still the gm
i don't know the answer to that i mean
you'd have to get mark
last time you talked to john gruden
uh we text back and forth occasionally
and
uh he called me after i got fired
so what's the future
i'm kind of excited you know i'm an old
guy and and it's good to be excited um
and i've never been afraid of a
challenge so i'm kind of i'm white i
watch tape every morning
uh
the challenge for me dan is that you
know if i watch tape from seven to ten
um go get a workout for an hour and a
half it's noon and now i got nothing to
do and i'm not used to that
that sounds like me mike i'm done at
noon and then i got nothing to do
i'm not used to that and i'm not you
know going 100 miles an hour
back to the speed limit is hard
but what i'm trying to do is i'm trying
to keep the balls up in the air i've had
some opportunities to go to nfl teams um
i've had some of my television people
call me
um i kind of look at this stan like
at age 63 i know me and i need to be
around football but whether it's an nfl
team whether it's doing television or in
all honesty i i could go coach the
defensive backs at haverford school
right down the street and be really
happy so i'm just trying to keep it all
up in the air and when the right
opportunity comes i think i'll know
can we have your uh raiders gear
you know what i did with it
you'll get a kick out of this
i took about 90 of it
uh before we left vegas and i drove down
to the local fire station
and i knocked on the door i didn't know
anybody i just knocked on the door and
this this fireman answered the door
and i said listen
it might sound silly but i just get
fired as the raiders gm
and i had two huge bags with me like
like trash bags i said i got all this
brand new gear and i think some of you
guys might like it or you can give it to
the community but i don't need it
anymore and the guy guy looked at me
like i was crazy he said well i think
you better meet the chief he took me
into the chief and i'm dragging two big
bags of crap into the chief
that's what i do with my raider gear
good to talk to you good luck stay in
touch mike thank you i appreciate you
dan thank you it's mike mayonk the
former raider gm some good stuff there